[Music]
well they say if you miss a little you
miss a lot and boy was there a lot over
the past 25 years
here on fox yep uh here it is ladies and
gentlemen and look back at some of the
top moments from fox and friends over
the last two and a half decades watch
[Music]
hey you gotta have a shot back yeah
wow
hi welcome to the program we've got a
new name folks it's no longer fox
express he is fox and friends excuse me
oh wait there's william shatner right
i can't get in
beam yourself in mr big shot easier
is there any chance you'll do a song
about this interview
don't know why
there are no clouds up in the sky stormy
what you called me steven i felt like i
was in trouble you are in trouble unless
you read this okay you guys at any point
comb your hair no
this is stylish how did you get your
hair to do that it's natural is that
right and i'm the sports guy brian kill
me today
you're a machine you're a machine
how do you stop this
i'm sorry that's how we stop it brian
sorry
ladies and gentlemen halle berry
performing
hello
harrison ford good morning
fine what are you doing here
good question it just so happens that uh
the world's number one britney
spearologist lives at my house when you
were in the mickey mouse club did you
ever see the guy in the mouse suit with
his head off
i would like to come back and drop your
name is that possible
oh no
okay that's amazing all right
oh my god story circulating on the
internet yeah that you are dating our
sports guy brian kilmeade anything to
that
are you serious i'm not to accept any
more uh outside assignments this is
panama city beach all these spring
breakers they're here to party
excuse me i've never had such a such a
hostile assistant chimp says true the
chimp is right the yellow that is
true
you represent the human race
don't yell at me you're the host
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey brian make sure you hit the bucket
it's coming out carbonated who's thirsty
do you want to take a swing at me just
yeah i do
[Music]
spit him around like that and i got him
in a chokehold like that there okay
what's your soup of the day
these are the current readings as you
can see currently in new york we got 50
degrees steve where are you going today
is my wife kathy's birthday i thought i
would go uh birthday shopping we go i'm
right over here there's ann taylor pull
over
thanks sam
you need a lift
good because we're full sorry pal mcfly
we've been looking for you you're late
i'm back to the future
this might be my favorite day on fox and
friends so far we are riding through new
york city in the ghostbuster mobile we
are gonna go to somebody's house they
don't know we're coming we're gonna make
you breakfast where's your kitchen when
was the last time you had puff pastry
never okay it's going to be fun good
luck we're going to start the blower
look at him grab the money oh my god he
is shameless
hey
it is the day of the big game and this
is what you take when you lose the uber
app all right yeah we're gonna we're
heading back to new york
worked well in rehearsal for years i've
been talking about the jet pack
[Music]
all right here we go let's go flying all
right
[Music]
awesome i actually kind of feel like the
guy fieri of fox diners drive-ins and
ducey it's like trying to manage kids
right now not so much i think i'm
cooking with kindergartners and they see
if you want to know what my scripts are
just look up there all right um is
steve coming back
it says steve on the prompt i brought
you guys with me too
facetime down here
museum i'm proud to be an american can
you tell i'm a reporter
yeah sure had involved big guy i should
have been a dentist
now on my phone do you watch fox and
friends every morning
man i love the news hello john rich
yes sir brian kilmeade we have a
celebrity stroller there's a problem
with coffee drinkers all know this that
you need the sugar to melt in the coffee
ainsley bought me a brand new coffee
kicked it over it's streaming behind the
sofa down there in the cables we need to
give him a sippy cup right oh that's
because
thank you very much well you're pardoned
for the dribbling of your coffee all day
all right i'll switch to my tie this is
upon further review of tide poorly oh no
i said you're gonna do that
all right it's okay
actually this is better muck fest ms a
cause that's very near and dear to my
heart my own janisteen the repelling
machine janice dean is live at
punxsutawney pennsylvania thank you for
bringing some fancy hats plus the hats
more hats
a woman not a loser thank you right
winner speaking of standing up that's
why jillian chooses to deliver the news
yep because brian said he won't let me
sit this program is according to the new
york times the most powerful tv show in
america because we have the best viewers
yeah what's your favorite morning show
[Applause]
how great was that all right now to mark
the official 25th anniversary
let's do it in five
four
three
two
one
[Applause]
very nice